sounds like you took medals from kids to
me yeah it sounds like you're a metal
snatcher dream catcher yeah dream
catcher Anthony
[Music]
you guys you guys are gonna dig this one
I picked this one up just for you boys
who
Northeastern University mistakenly sends
out 4 000 acceptance letters to law
school applicants oh
oh [ __ ] oh no how do you fix that [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah if everyone's all excited and
happy and their [ __ ] parents like I
knew you could too and they're all
lawsuited so they can go I'm gonna sue
you for whatever that's the best part
yeah yeah that's the best part then you
can see who actually deserves to be in
it ah hey unless they like [ __ ] class
action that [ __ ] and they're like hey
everybody everybody want to do it
together oh yeah you're like hey hey
people don't work together
how many were they supposed to accept
we'll get there Lakeisha Papa you're
gonna name them all [ __ ] it you [ __ ]
say it you're a woman I don't know how
to say This Woman's name I'm a woman
yeah you're a woman you gotta take
jurisdiction women shouldn't say this
give it your best shot sweetheart
oh is it a Greek a Greek name she gets
an email Monday at 2 00 p.m this is like
last Monday right
welcoming her to North East
northeastern's JD class of 2026 she had
applied to the program twice already as
a busy single mother of four schools
flexible instruction fit into her
schedule she's getting real yet a single
mother of four years you gotta let her
in now I gotta let her in they have to I
was I was over the moon she told Boston
yeah I bet she was Papa's out wow kiss I
got you uh that just says boston.com
good point
uh probably should go to the doctor
because I don't know what I saw okay she
excitedly called and emailed her friends
and family to show the news her early
decision acceptance included a
Northeastern ID number mayor
scholarships feels pretty real oh [ __ ]
and two requirements she must rescind
all other law school applications and
pay a 500 enrollment deposit oh she's in
it was very detailed and much more than
congratulations she said oh this is a
scam she then immediately went to pay
the deposit but couldn't get the website
to work she tried emailing the school to
report the problem but nobody reached
out oh it was a scam at 7 48. p.m
another email came in from Northwest
Northeastern
the email rescinded the offer blaming
the acceptance on a technology issue
uh-oh oh so it really was a mistake due
to a technical error they said 205
current applicants to the school of law
received an erroneous email notifying
them 205 out of 4 000 notifying them of
their acceptance into next year's class
admissions decisions will not be
finalized
uh later in the academic year they said
and then she just says she's devastated
she's like probably like emotionally
[ __ ] up she's like has anxiety now she
has her anxiety says it has anxiety now
absolutely yeah I don't blame her man
that's [ __ ] that is [ __ ] pretty good
lawsuit coming probably that's gonna
feel real [ __ ] to be like have a [ __ ]
party with your family over this thing
that happened and it wasn't even he's
like I can feed you guys now right after
I finish law school yeah but she's too
anxious to send out a letter or follow
along no so now now it's called damages
so is it 205 incorrect ones out of 4 000
so 300 uh 3930 applicants who applied
over a year ago the email was sent to
200 current applicants that they got
accepted but they're not yeah but
they're not accepted that's definitely
better than [ __ ] four thousand I'll
say that but this is sexier way to open
just let Amanda the extra 200 people
just let a man do is this gonna happen
me on a smaller scale so I have a
certain certification for work it's like
a cscs thing it's through like a
national assert whatever Counter-Strike
and every year you have to uh you have
to re-up against CEUs you gotta do it
every year every two years you see it's
like it's like a continuing education
and credit units right can you do that
online you gotta do like seminars you
gotta do all that [ __ ] they sent me an
email recently yeah stop falling asleep
do this report email saying I completed
all the requirements and I was like I
didn't even do that yet
and then I was like oh man just so you
did it awesome yeah [ __ ] yeah then they
sent me another email saying hey we sent
it out to everybody oh sorry oh you
still have to do your CEUs and I was
like damn it dude and now I have all
this [ __ ] anxiety now and your
anxiety's got anxiety now I can't
[ __ ] trust I don't even open any
emails anymore how many hours of ceu you
got to do hey that's affecting your work
that's damages it's like it's like five
units or something and each thing that I
have to do is like 0.3 CEUs so then I
gotta do a bunch of [ __ ] did they say
the following people did not get
accepted and then in parenthesis you
just said Nick's done yeah and they're
like you're gonna have to check it out
to everybody yeah to everybody and they
said Nick Dunn didn't do a CEUs yet so
[ __ ] done you know this [ __ ] is over
for him his career is over and I'm just
sitting in a home like this
so what happened to me I can empathize
with these people yes the very same
thing that's the point you and your four
children
single dad of four so this ma of four is
saying she's just made by the Glitch
she's not given up on her legal
aspirations
and she has chosen to sue the school no
I wish it said that she just says I
wanted to be a lawyer my whole life the
university needs to make a greater
effort to rectify what they did but
she's not giving up on trying to be
alone what's uh what would be a good
rectification if you did all just let
her in dude but what if she's like
dismally [ __ ] like an idiot that she
gotta figure it out she can't get out
you know what I mean because you still
gotta like pass the bar to get out and
get your license so [ __ ] let her in
yeah and if she's gonna spend 12 years
in law school then [ __ ] it you know dude
a lot of schools get in trouble for like
especially like Master's programs they
accept a gang of people just because
it's expensive they get paid out yeah
knowing that they can't make it and then
they just don't they they just create
like really poor people in that that
industry hey well that's what they say
about uh what is it called like inner
city schools when they adjust the curve
to let more of them in from
underprivileged counties and then they
just don't do as well because they
didn't get the proper education to be
able to thrive but then that one teacher
at the school is super dramatic and at
the first day of their life
look to your left look to your right
one of y'all is not gonna make it yeah
that's what happens in both of them yeah
the whole class disappears you're not
gonna make it and they're in Ronald
McDonald University and then like yeah
we will we're yeah we're fine we're fine
Scott's tots
I think 200 people yeah like going into
that school let's say how much does on
average law school realistically so uh
the current first year class at
Northeastern has 234 students oh so when
you accidentally send it to 205 people
in the wrong way that's a whole ass
class oh [ __ ] damn that's like fully
doubling your resources that's like if
you normally have like 40 students in
class now you have 80. it's a big
mistake it's a pretty big oofy doofy
yeah that's a huge what can you do
like if you're not if you're let's say
you're the school you already know and
they're like let's say Nick you're in
charge of thinking the solution and
they're like don't let them in find some
other way to make them happy what else
is there you gotta send them to
Northwestern Chicago yeah yeah open up
another school just send them a
participation award saying that they're
a lawyer yeah exactly or we go hey
world's best lawyer [ __ ] mugs and a
mug the best we could do is the summer
accelerated program
and it's going to cause a double oh wow
but you get done quicker that's where
you set up okay and then they all
probably still fail because it's
probably no way you can condense all
that material in the summer
so Jeffrey Jeffrey s Bornstein who is
the managing partner at Northeastern
University says while we didn't oofi we
we definitely haven't do feed yet we
plan on rectifying the situation by
undoofing the oofy and allowing these
students to resubmit for application so
that's basically what they're doing
they're just
so if you oofy that's an adjective oh we
[ __ ] up but if you do feed it's in
cement it's we really [ __ ] it yeah so
something I actually do have a chance
that they just received a erroneous like
random things exactly but maybe some of
them will get it oh got it okay so
there's hope there's hope for some but
for some it's a total doofy but for some
it's a Newfie yeah I think that that's
that's the legal term man I just relate
to this so hard right I'm just using his
words Honestly though at the same time
to be uh maybe like minimize damage type
thing if we were the university we did
that and maybe we got like 500 from them
everybody who like accidentally got the
thing they deposit 500 what if we're
like hey pizza party we'll give you back
a thousand
you don't make the school but it's like
you made 500 bucks for getting the wrong
email oh like is that like kind of
rational almost pay you a couple hundred
bucks that's something they want to get
into school obviously but that's what
I'm saying but we're not gonna let you
in the school anyway we know you want to
get in this constellation prize but I
can't let you in but you told me I could
get in the pizza party is pretty good
though either way you're not getting in
if you want a thousand dollars or not
you take the 500 they pay pizza party
I'm telling you if it's especially if
it's a local spot you're not just using
a chain yeah that's pretty good yeah you
get a pizza party hopefully there's a
good Shakey's in our neighborhood that'd
be good potatoes yeah we're good there
was a uh this is like a small scale
version of this but there's uh I was
judging a dance competition like one of
the more like major ones and then uh
as we tallied up the scores okay this
team got first place it's got second
it's got third we gave it to the lady to
like write it on a paper for the
announcer I hate moments like this God
damn it they announced oh the winner is
this team yeah okay cool you guys got
second grade blah blah we [ __ ] go
back to our like judges room then that
lady comes back and she goes hey that
wasn't that wasn't the same thing as the
score sheets and then we looked at it
the lady who had wrote it just the
in-between lady to give it to the answer
wrote it in the wrong order oh my God
and this was after we'd already awarded
all the teams were celebrating you're
supposed to say runner-up first right
well she just went one two three wrote
it wrong completely it's like a Miss
America yeah so maybe like three and one
were switched or something like that
yeah so they they had switched first so
what do you do at that point yeah so
then we talked about it we're like okay
obviously we got to tell them so let's
just bring them uh both both heads of
the two teams back in here so we brought
them back it was the and it was really
sweet because uh it couldn't have up
into the sweeter like the sweetest
[ __ ] people in the dance world like
the the two directors were just like oh
my God that's so weak that's crazy we
thought we won but that's totally fine
like they deserved it they were so good
and then the other lady was like oh my
God thank you so much like they were
super nice
super loud that [ __ ] happened to me in
Spain and and this is one of those
situations where it's like a bunch of
kids teams and then as the judge to the
guest judge you have to go there and
then one by one you have to put a medal
on each [ __ ] kid oh my God and then
we went back and then they were like hey
we actually did the wrong one and
they're like hey can you go back on
stage and take them back from there oh
my God and I was like back and I was
like [ __ ] for the kids and then a
grandma from one of the teams when they
like they announced it it was incorrect
a grandma and other people they started
running up to us and cussing us out in
Spanish and I like yelled at the host
and I was like you need to [ __ ] get
on the mic and tell them it wasn't our
bad you literally are [ __ ] up our
entire credibility and reputation
[ __ ] mic they had to get on and
apologize in front of everybody and [ __ ]
like that wow I was like I'm getting on
stage taking medals from kids as you
[ __ ] fix it yourself right it was
crazy it sounds like you took medals
from kids to me yeah it sounds like
you're a metal snatcher I got paid
that's not that's all that matters but
everybody else I just wanted to be dream
catcher yeah dream catcher Anthony
he's like these kids need to come down
to planet Earth huh
[Music]